I'm Janice Dean I'm David Asman I'm Dana
Perino and this is the Fox News rundown
Friday April 10th 2020 I'm Chris Foster
remember the presidential campaign sound
at Trump versus Biden and Fox News
Sunday host Chris Wallace says now I
think this will be a referendum on how
Donald Trump handled the coronavirus I'm
not sure that that this Biden's issues
and you know his record and stuff is
gonna be all that important
and Lisa Brady for Christians and Jews
this is supposed to be a time of
celebration and many will find new ways
to share that joy keeping hope and faith
alive maybe faith doesn't take away all
the pain but if it can keep us hoping
for a better future hoping for an
ultimate solution that is a great gift
and I'm Robert Jeffress I've got the
final word on the Fox News rundown
[Music]
now that the presidential campaigns the
first thing on most people's minds these
days but we do end the week with one
Democratic Party presidential candidate
left standing I am announcing the
suspension of my campaign Bernie Sanders
tells supporters he can't win
while we are winning the ideological
battle and while we are winning the
support of so many young people and
working people throughout the country I
have concluded that this battle for the
Democratic nomination will not be
successful
big news like this in a presidential
race is a reminder of the olden days
like three or four weeks ago when we
were actually talking about the campaign
and who was winning primaries absolutely
you know it's interesting because when
he dropped out of the race this week you
kind of had it was kind of a shock not
that he dropped out but he kind of had
to remind us of oh yeah there's a
presidential race going on and there's a
Democratic primary going on and people
still care about it Chris Wallace is the
host of Fox News Sunday Bernie Sanders
had to drop out I'm sure he came under
tremendous pressure from party leaders
they need to do everything they can to
prepare for the fall to raise money to
build Organization for Joe Biden to take
on a Donald Trump and there was no
chance that Bernie Sanders at this point
was going to win the nomination I think
he had a traumatic effect on the on the
Democratic race I think he moved the
party considerably to the left on health
issues I mean think of some of the
things that even Joe Biden who's running
as the relative centrist or moderate
although he's certainly pretty liberal
is endorsing now that were just
unacceptable he's a a public option not
Medicare for all but a public option
that wasn't something that rock obama
supported in 2012 health care for
illegal immigrants that wasn't something
that barack obama supported in 2012
decriminalizing people coming across the
border same probe ama so there certainly
is some difference and distance between
where Sanders is and Biden is but Biden
is a lot closer to Bernie Sanders than
he is to where Barack Obama was
just four years ago yeah he's gonna have
to walk a line to where he wants to keep
he wants to draw and progressives but
not turn off the people who were turned
off by Bernie going forward now three
more I think that's a very delicate
dance he's gonna have to do he does have
to move to the left and he you know he
say it uses this when I hear you to
Bernie supporters he's gonna have to do
more than hear them he's gonna have to
support some of the things that they
want but you know there's I there's a
reason that Bernie Sanders might have
had a really tough time against Donald
Trump because Trump was ready to label
him a socialist he'll probably try to do
the same but fightin but Biden has got
to make it clear he's not as far to the
left as Bernie Sanders if he's gonna
pick up the moderates the independents
the suburban Republican women that he
desperately needs if he's gonna beat
Donald Trump in November the campaign is
sort of in this to spending animation
with everybody just talking about
coronavirus do you think that Biden is
blowing an opportunity here by not
stepping up and saying hey here's what
we need to do or is he better off just
kind of covering his face with his
gloves and writing this out I have to
say I don't think if he if he were you
know I know he's doing podcasts and and
virtual town halls and press conferences
from the basement of his home in
Delaware I honestly don't think he it
matters much because I don't think
people are paying much attention and he
just he's not the president what he's
saying isn't really gonna matter that
much I actually it's gonna sound odd I
think to some degree he may benefit from
the fact that he's off the screen to the
degree that and this won't last but
because obviously as we get more no
matter what condition the country is in
after Labor Day this will be a Biden
versus Trump race and you'll be sure
that Trump will paint you know portray
all of what he believes or Joe Biden
shortcomings and it's record and some of
the statements he's made but I think to
the degree that Biden can kind of ride
this out for right now and because
people aren't paying attention and be
more the generic Democrat I think the
generic Democrat ones that are a
Donald Trump then Joe Biden does and and
I think to some degree this election is
going to be a coronavirus referendum on
Donald Trump if in the end you know it
when we get to next November and I we
don't know the answer to this
people think that Trump has handled the
the health issue and the economic issue
well I think he may be unbeatable and if
people come to the conclusion a majority
of Americans that he has handled a
health issue and the economic issue
poorly I don't think he has any chance
to win so to a certain degree I think
this will be a referendum on how Donald
Trump handled the coronavirus I'm not
sure that that that Biden's issues and
you know his record and the stuff is
going to be all that important yeah if
we've had if we have a couple of months
a couple quarters excuse me of recession
if we're in a recession by the time the
election rolls around even though the
president can obviously rightfully claim
that it's because of the virus
I don't know can somebody be reelected
in the middle of a recession if we've
got ten percent unemployment and empty
storefronts in town after town well you
know it's a pretty extraordinary
experience then you know the initial
answer the obvious answer will be no you
know the economy is what people vote on
and the president is gonna get credit or
blame probably more but this is such a
runoff I mean it hasn't happened in this
country this you know in in terms of a
pandemic since nineteen seventeen
eighteen as the president reminds us
with the Spanish flu does he get the
full run of the blame for something
which clearly he had nothing to do it
but you know I in the end I think that
people will will make a judgement
they'll say did he handle the health
crisis properly did he handle the
economic crisis properly or not I will
be a tougher argument to make of people
are still suffering what in the last
three weeks we've had seventeen million
new Americans claim unemployment go on
unemployment that's that you know people
that that's horrible
but it but politically acceptable in
April is it acceptable and
in September and October probably not
yeah I mean we're just having this
theoretical conversation maybe the maybe
things bounce back faster or maybe
things bounce back slower and I guess
the conversation could be had then now
I'm sure you're looking forward to if
President Trump is elected I'm sure
we'll get hearings on his on his
coronavirus response oh absolutely I
don't know but I'm looking forward to it
but you know Nancy Pelosi has set up
this coronavirus committee and and and
it's a legitimate issue no it's like
after 9/11 you want to find out what
could have been handled better what
could have been handled worse I think
you'll have that whether Donald Trump is
re-elected or not because lord knows we
don't want to go through this again and
there are always lessons you can learn
whether it's to have you know we last
week on Fox News Sunday I had an
interview with Bill Gates and we played
this extraordinary and I would recommend
this to all of your listeners and I
don't want you to go away from Fox radio
to too much but just Google Bill Gates
2015 TED talk and it's an eight and a
half minute tape it's been last week it
had been viewed by 26 million people
overall probably more than that now and
he it just astonishingly lays out the
threat from a pandemic he didn't know
was gonna be the corona virus coming
from China but he said the next thing
that's gonna kill millions of people in
the in the world will not be a war it's
going to be a pandemic and he laid out
so many of the things that we needed to
do to prepare that we didn't do and this
isn't a partisan thing this was in 2015
when Barack Obama was president so you
know there's enough blame to go around
you know you hope we're gonna learn some
lessons from this we're gonna have paid
a terrible price in both blood and
treasure but you would hope that that
will learn some lessons and we'll be
better prepared when and it seems
inevitable whether it's 10 years from
now or a hundred years from now
something like this happens again one
more Christie's daily coronavirus Task
Force briefings are you seeing
diminishing returns from them just as a
news guy somebody who wants to learn
about what's Happ
with the virus and somebody was watching
the politics of it where President Trump
is in a way besides using these for
information he's sort of replacing his
his campaign rallies with these I
I see diminishing returns on both fronts
I think that you know not that I I say
this with political reporters are all
frustrated campaign managers or White
House advisors or whatever but you know
so I don't expect anybody to take any
advice it's worth how much I'm getting
paid for which is nothing but I think
that they go on too long I think there
should be much shorter and I think that
it when they when the president
initially began them they seem to be
much more about facts and what's going
on to fight the virus you could you saw
spike and the president's approval now
you're saying it actually go down and
you know the president is getting into
fights governors and with reporters and
you know I I think he would be well
advised to just give the facts maybe
take a few coronavirus questions and get
off the stage and leave it to the less
political people like you know the
health officials the economic officials
the you know people from the CDC and and
from Public Health and the supply chain
FEMA I think they would that would serve
the president better politically and it
would serve the country better in terms
of getting the information they really
want I think I think that they they have
kind of turned into rallies and I don't
think that's helping them right now
Chris Wallace host of Fox News Sunday
thanks once again for coming on the Fox
News rundown today you you bet thanks a
lot
[Music]
this is Robert Jeffress with your
FoxNews commentary
coming up there are a few things this
pandemic can't cancel or postpone but it
changes everything and what's happening
this week would have been unthinkable
just a few months ago for the legions of
faithful around the world Holy Week and
Easter without Church Passover without
temple houses of worship
among the many places that have had to
close their doors as we all do battle
against kovat 19 but services are still
being held virtually let us pray and not
just the big ones like st. Patrick's
Cathedral in New York City local places
of worship are streaming to priests and
rabbis using modern technology to keep
tradition and faith alive their
congregations worshiping from home where
we're doing just about everything these
days though keeping the faith can be a
different kind of struggle there's
belief but there's also doubt together
with that belief and I think that's a
very normal human experience Jonathan
Morris is a theologian and Fox News
contributor and when there's deep
suffering in our lives that doubt comes
into contact with faith in a way that is
sometimes very hard and even I would say
existentially difficult for us I believe
in an all-powerful all-loving God and
yet he has allowed this to happen and
how does that how do those two beliefs
or two realities coincide right this is
a real a crisis like this is a real test
of faith yeah it is and you see on the
one hand for most people faith gets them
through very difficult times and help to
help them not lose hope right and and
then in the end not losing hope is a
huge thing
maybe faith doesn't take away all the
pain but if it can keep us hoping for a
better future hoping for an ultimate
solution that is a great gift and I
think faith in the midst of suffering
offers us a
most important gift for those who like
to actively practice their faith it's a
really difficult thing to to not have
the option to go to church and I know
where I live in Connecticut and our
local parish at least some of the
churches are still staying open if you
want to be able to walk in and light a
candle for instance but the services are
only being done online you can watch the
service online yeah I look at it as kind
of a fast right there's people who do
fasting for purely physiological
purposes I'm gonna you know it fasting
is now gonna invoke from a physical
perspective but fasting is a long-held
tradition in not only the Catholic
Church that you reference but so many
traditions the idea of giving up
something or doing without something for
a time in order to prepare the spirit
for something else sometimes we get so
used to things even good things like
liturgical services like going to mass
like going to your local church like
hearing homilies that we get used to
them and they don't penetrate us as
deeply so I would say yes it is a hard
time for us to be able to for us to have
to not attend what we're used to
attending but it can also be a great
moment of sensitizing the soul once
again absence makes the heart grow
fonder in a way I think so perhaps it's
also it also strikes me that it sort of
calls to mind a lot of religious beliefs
from the standpoint of helping your
fellow man and woman you know caring for
each other as humans so in this case
staying away from each other is kind of
the best way to do it for now you know
today I I ran it into a gentleman who's
blind as he was walking down the street
right in front of my apartment and I
think it was because of what we're going
through that I even noticed him as bad
as that sounds right we're so used to
encountering so many things people
activities and especially in a in a big
city like New York City where where I am
you you
- stay in your lane just to survive or
at least we convinced ourselves of that
so I saw this gentleman I went over I
asked him if you needed help I just felt
like he must be going through things
right now that are even more scary than
the rest of us and he accepted help
walked a few blocks and I thought to
myself how terrible that I don't usually
see this gentleman or other gentleman
other women in their situation so yes
this is a very strange time and it can
be very a timeful of anxiety but it's
also time that sensitizes us to the
needs of others and i think that's a
beautiful thing
well it certainly kind of eye-opening
and refreshing on on some levels people
know you as a former priest are you
getting inundated with questions about
this pandemic during this time I decided
I'm going to do a daily Facebook live
video and and I'm starting to do one
each day you can just go to Jonathan
Moore's just look up the verified page
under Jonathan Morris on Facebook but
people do ask questions in hard times
and we all need answers and they and the
temptation I think is to think that
because we're not a priest or because we
are not a pastor or because we are not a
you know they have degrees in theology
or whatever that we can't help somebody
we all can help somebody and I think we
have to make that decision I'm going to
get over my insecurities and go and do
it maybe it means just my neighbor or my
sibling or my friends but I'm going to
do my part
more human interaction even though we
can't interact more in person right now
you can still have more interaction you
can still reach out to people my mom
told me she's always telling me what to
say on in the media how her ideas but
she told me what she's doing is making a
list of every day of who she can reach
out to who might need someone in their
life
as simple as a phone call a letter a
note a text message FaceTime we get so
used to having people available to us
and being available to other people and
time flies by and sometimes we don't
even have that availability when we can
now that we can't have that same
availability I think it's a great
reminder to find new ways to reach out
and to be for somebody a little bit of
compassion and joy is there any other
single piece of advice that you want to
pass on to people at this time a lot of
us are self isolating right we are
neither self quarantine if there's some
some reason to believe that we've been
in contact with somebody who has been
infected or for the rest of us just kind
of self isolating that is a very lonely
situation for many many people and I
think we have to find ways to make sure
that the loneliness doesn't win things
as simple as making sure you make your
bed in the morning to shower get out of
your pajamas at least once a day do
things make it to do lists decide that
we're gonna be productive and we can be
productive in 2020 in ways from our
homes and ways that we could never have
been productive even 20 years ago and so
we can decide we're not going to let the
loneliness win but we're going to be on
the hands and feet I would say of Jesus
I would say as a Christian to be the
hands and feet of Jesus for people who
are in more difficult situations than we
are especially for the faithful I guess
to remind ourselves constantly were
never alone we aren't alone that's a
great way to put it we're not alone and
we can hear the voice of God whispering
to us and our conscience and in our
heart theologian and Fox News
contributor Jonathan Morris a pleasure
to meet you Sarah thanks for being here
thank you Lisa
from the Fox News podcasts Network
download and listen to the untold story
with Martha McCallum the host of the
story on Fox News Channel sits down with
major newsmakers each week to get their
untold story subscribe and listen now by
going to Fox News podcasts com
subscribe to this podcast at Fox News
podcasts com and now some good news with
Tanya J powers
Cassie woods and her husband Simon
thought when they lost their camera full
of pictures from their dream vacation
that was it they'd never see them again
it happened on a trip to the Dominican
Republic in April 2018 when their kayak
rolled over and their hero for GoPro
camera disappeared in the water the
camera spent 18 months underwater before
it was spotted by Ryan Friday Swan a
fellow British tourists who were
snorkeling in September last year near
Punta Cana on his honeymoon not far from
where Cassie and her husband had stayed
the GoPro was full of mud but after some
cleaning the memory card came through
with Cassie's photos intact
Ryan vowed to hunt down the cameras
owners which is where a Facebook group
comes in the Facebook page called lost
box is a group that tries to reunite
found items with their owners Ryan
posted some of the pictures on the site
with a plea to ask if anyone could help
get the camera back to its original
owners within a day Facebook users had
tracked down Cassie she now has her
camera and her priceless photos back and
says the effort Ryan made to get it to
her was touching and that quote there
are really kind people out there
Tonya J powers Fox News
[Music]
it's time for your Fox News commentary
Robert Jeffress what's on your mind
how can a good all-powerful God allow so
much suffering in our world this
question has plagued philosophers and
theologians for millennia but it's not
just an academic or a theoretical
problem the problem of suffering
confronts us all Jobe the righteous man
talked around and around this question
with his friends in the midst of his
darkest days
he lost his children his house and his
health all in a moment he cried out for
the thing that I fear comes upon me and
what I dread befalls me I am not at ease
nor am i quiet
I have no rest but trouble comes every
day in our fractured world someone is
having their own Jobe moment when
everything they have is suddenly taken
away but it's rare for all of us to
share in a Jobe moment together that's
what the corona virus pandemic has felt
like at its worst covin 19 has taken
loved ones or has them barely clinging
to life in overcrowded I see use for
others the symptoms of the virus have
knocked them down with fatigue and pain
for weeks on end even those who have not
experienced the virus have experienced
the fear of contracting it and the
isolation of avoiding it some have lost
their livelihoods or watched their
life-savings diminish we are all in our
job moment in the easter story Christ
experienced his own Jobe moment he was
betrayed by his closest friends mocked
and beaten and sentenced to a slow and
excruciating death but Christ embraced
his Jobe moment and took on suffering
willingly in obedience to the Father and
for the sake of our salvation this is
why Jobe could confidently say centuries
before Christ coming for I know that my
redeemer lives and at the last he will
stand upon the earth and after my skin
is been
thus destroyed yet in my flesh I shall
see God
we too can turn to Christ from the
depths of our job moment placing our
faith in the one who has conquered death
and secured eternal life
I'm Robert Jeffress you've been
listening to the bucs news rundown and
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at FoxNews podcasts calm and for
up-to-the-minute news go to Fox news.com
[Music]
the news and opinion you trust and click
the FoxNews rundown playlist for the
latest episodes